ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
คณะเปลี่ยนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนรู้เองวันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันจันทร์ค่ะโอเคดูจากสีที่ผู้
หญิงเขียนใช่ก็เอดส์จำไม่ได้วันนั้นอะไร
วันจันทร์ที่ไอ้ผู้หญิงนะคะอุ้ยคุยอีก
แล้วแล้วพี่เอ๋เสียวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับผู้
หญิงที่เห็นไหนวันที่ 6 ค่ะว่าเรียนอะไร
คะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะ
2565 มีความสุขค่ะตีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ค่ะ
2022 ครูเอ๋ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วเวลาจะ
15:00 น
43 น
บ่าย 3 โมงสี่สิบสามนาที
ผู้หญิงลืมค่ะจุดกันกับกูฟ้าจะไปนอนหนูนะ
คะ
งงไปหมดเลย
02:13
อันนี้ตีสนามนั้นเป็นนอนหนูเนี่ยครูเอ๋
สบายดีนะคะสบายดีค่ะครูหญิงล่ะคะสบายดี
ไหมคะบาร์เย็นสบายดีค่ะมีคำถามอีกแล้วค่ะ
ครูเอ๋อยากคุยไม่ทันนักเรียนนะคะพักนี้กู
หญิงไม่ถึงมากนักเรียนเลยนะคะนักเรียนที่
สามคนสวัสดีค่ะผู้หญิงขอโทษค่ะนักเรียน
บางครั้งผู้หญิงก็ลืมนักเรียนก็ไม่เป็นไร
หรอ
นักเรียนผู้ชายผู้หญิงของเราสึก 3 คนนะคะ
คะตอนนี้ใช้ค่ะกินเข้ามาเกาหลี
เมื่อวันที่ 14 นะคะมายคราสิบปีอยู่ที่
ไหนอยู่ที่ไหนนะคะถามเดี๋ยวโอกาสหน้าเรา
จะทักนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะตอนนี้นั่งเล่น
โกรธอ่ะครูลืมฉันหรือยังไม่ลืมไม่ลืมครู
อยากสอบอยากจะสอนภาษาไทย
ลืมสวัสดีคุณธาราชิดสวัสดีคุณ John
สวัสดีคุณเขาคุณลิซ่าคุณปวีณาคุณแตฮีคุณ
โรเบิร์ตคุณรัตน์พิศคุณอะไรอีกนะ List
คุณโอคุณ HC อีน
นะคะคุณศาลาศาลาด้วยใช่มั้ยคนที่ 12
โอเคค่ะวันนี้กูหญิงมีคำถามครูเอ๋ไปค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ย
อันนี้อะไรคะครูเหตุไอ้โอ้นี่นะคะมั้ย
of อะไรอ่ะไม่ค่อยพูด Phone  Microphone
เนี่ยก็ร้องเพลงใช่ไหมคะเครื่องนั้นๆร้อง
เพลง
ทำไมคุณตกใจขนาดนั้นไม่
ใช่เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะคิดว่าแบบเฮ้ยทำไมครู
หญิงไม่บอกครูเอกจะได้คิดร้องเพลงอะไรก็
เลยแบบตกใจว่าไม่ๆๆๆค่ะไม่ใช่ตกใจว่าครู
เอร้องเพลงนักเรียนกดปิดทำไมไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
เลยใช่เลยบอกไม่ฟัง
เวลาเราร้องเพลงอะไรก็จะมีคนเนี่ยอาจจะ
เป็นผู้ชายนะคะหรือว่าผู้หญิง
ว่าที่เลยใช่ไหมผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงที่ขอ
ร้องเพลงเราเรียกอะไรคะครูเอ๋นะร้องค่ะ
จ่ายนักร้องใช่มั้ย Justin  Bieber เงี้ย
เป็นนักร้อง
แจ็กสันเอาคนที่ยังไม่ตายเนี่ยเอ้อสาย
ก็กูเอชอบอะไรนะชอบดีขึ้นลินดิอออนใช่
มั้ยซิลิกา
เป็นนักร้องก็มีนักร้องเวลาร้องเพลงมันก็
ต้องมีผู้ชาย
ปากกำลังคิดชื่อนักร้องเอนย่าหัวนัก
ร้องอะไรก็ไม่รู้ Taylor  Swift สิคะเฮ็ด
หยังผู้หญิงคุณต้องฟังเอนย่าผู้หญิงฟังหา
นักเรียนคิดว่ากูหญิงไม่เคยฟังเอนย่าเหรอ
คะ
อะไรนะนักร้องไม่เป็นไรนักร้องดีมากๆค่ะ
ใจค่ะมีนักร้องแต่เวลานักร้องที่ร้องเพลง
บนเวทีนี้เป็นเวทีคะแล้วก็พูดเราก็ดูอยู่
ที่นี่มีนักร้องร้องเพลงก็ต้องมีผู้ชาย
ที่เขาอาจจะมี
อะไรเนี่ย
ฮะกีต้าร์เหรอค่ะใช่ไหมถึงชายไม่ใช่ค่ะ
คิดว่าปลากูเอกเก่งมากเลยนะเพราะว่ากู
เห็นกูอายรู้ว่ามึงจะพูดอะไรนะฮะพูดนาย
หรือว่า Guitar  Bass
Guitar ค่ะติดตานะคะกี่หน้าผู้ชายที่
เล่นกีต้าร์หรือว่าอาจจะเล่นคีย์บอร์ด
Keyboard เนี่ย
ขอบผู้ชายดิบกีต้าร์ใช่ไหมจ่ายดีดกีตาร์
ถ้าดีดกีตาร์ก็ได้ใส่คะเล่นกีต้าร์เล่น
คีย์บอร์ดเนี่ยค่ะเราเรียกอะไรคะครูเอ๋
นักดนตรีค่ะ
จ่ายมีนักร้องก็ต้องมีนัดดนตรีนะแต่ว่า
วันนี้นะคะเราไม่ได้พูดนักร้องไม่เอาค่ะ
ไม่ชอบนักร้องค่ะวันนี้ทำไมล่ะคะเอาเราจะ
พูดถึง
นักดนตรีหรอคะ
ไม่ค่ะเราพูดถึงดนตรีเครื่องดนตรี
ออมไม่เอานักดนตรีนักดนตรีออกไปรักมนตรี
ไม่เอาค่ะไม่เอาไม่เอานะฮะเราจะพูด
เครื่องดนตรีค่ะสมัยกีตาร์คีย์บอร์ดเนี่ย
เป็นเครื่องดนตรี
แต่เวลาเล่นเล่นไม่เหมือนกันอ๋อ
นี่ผู้หญิงมีกีตาร์ให้ดูอันนี้กีตาร์อะไร
คะคุณรู้จักกีต้าร์ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงไม่ค่อย
รู้จักกีต้าร์กีต้าร์โป่ง 5 กีต้าร์โปร่ง
เนี่ยครูเอ๋คะเวลานักเราเล่นกีตาร์เนี่ย
เราเล่นยังไงเราเล่นล่ะคะเราก็ต้องข้อมือ
สายไหมบางคนมือขวามือขวากดมือซ้ายกดกูเอก
เคยต้องมือซ้ายกดสายขีตาอ่อตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
คะสายกีตาร์เอาใส่เป็นสีนี้เลยดิเดี๋ยว
เพลงเปลี่ยนสีก่อนนะพี่ใช่ไหมสายกีตาร์
เอามือซ้ายกดสายกีตาร์อ้าวแล้วมือขวาล่ะ
คะทำอะไรมือขวาเนี่ยจะต้องใช้สองนิ้วใช่
ไหมคะบางคนก็ไม่ใช้นะก็มีเขาเรียกว่าปิ๊ก
อาจะแบบนี้ปิ๊กแล้วก็ใช้ปิ๊กเนี่ยดีดค่ะ
ง่ายๆใส่ให้กีตาร์ดีตรงนี้นะใช่น้าสาย
กีต้าร์แต่บางคนก็ใช้เล็บใช่มือเนี่ยจริง
ๆใช้ใช้เล็บดีดราคา silent  sigh ค่ะเวลา
ไม่มีค่ะสีเล็บเพิ่งตัดไปเองเสต็ปเนี่ย
เดี๋ยวไม่ดำเชื่อคุยเมื่อไหร่แล้วผู้หญิง
คิดว่าขาวอาหารเล็บอ่ะดีดใช่ไหมเราต้องดี
ใช่ค่ะ
นี่ไงพี่มีรูปนี่เห็นไหมคะที่กูเอ๋บอกใช้
มือหนึ่งข้างอะไรล่ะกดหน้าส่วนในกีตาร์
อีกข้างหนึ่งก็ดีด
ผู้หญิงดีดกีตาร์เป็นไหมคะไม่เป็นค่ะครู
เอ๋ดีกีตาร์เป็นไหมคะ
ดีดได้แต่ไม่เป็น
ผู้หญิงก็ดีดได้กับครูเอ๋
ใครก็กิน
รู้เหรอเคยเรียนแต่ว่าเวลากดแล้วครูเห็น
เจ็บอ๋อ
กดสายกีต้าร์มันเป็น n ใช่ไหมสายเอ็นน่ะ
แล้วกดลงไปแล้วโหมีน้ำตาไหลเจ็บ
ชายชายคุยก็เลยไม่เล่นเหมือนกันค่ะกูเอก
ก็เลยไม่เล่นกีตาร์เพราะว่าเจ็บนิ้วนะค่ะ
เพราะไม่ต้องใช้นิ้วกดแล้วก็ดีดใช่ไหมคะ
ดีด
สิ่งมีอีกแถวคู๋ไม่รู้ไหมคะเครื่องดนตรี
อันนี้อะไรไม่ใช่กี่ตาใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่
กีต้าร์แล้วค่ะ
ไม่มีภาษาไทยเนาะไวโอลินที่ว่าไวโอลิน
ไวโอลินเนี่ยเวลาเล่นเล่นยังไงดีเหมือน
กีตาร์ไหมเออไม่ดีดไม่ดีแล้วเล่นยังไงคะ
ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะเขามีไม้อันนี้ใช่ไหม
หมายไม้เขามีตัวไวโอลินใช่ไหมคะไวโอลีน
น่ะมีเส้นแมดเซน
เส้นอันเนี้ยเส้นเอ็นเนาะเหมือน
พบกับกีตาร์ดูแล้วก็คล้ายๆกีต้าร์
ซ้ายนะเขียนไม่เหมือนคล้ายนะคะสะแปลว่า
ไม่ต้องดีดกีตาร์ในเข้าจับแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็กดแล้วก็ดีดไวโอลินในเข้ามาโอเค
เอาไว้ตรงไหน
ที่นี่ไหมที่บ่า
แล้วก็มีไม้ใช่ 4 สีค่ะผู้หญิง
เก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋นี่นี่เห็นไหมเหมือน
ภูเขาก็ไม่ได้ที่บ้านนะคะไว้ตก
น้ำแล้วก็ใช้ 2 คนไม่เป็น
เนี่ยเสียง 4
ไม่รู้เป็นไร
ลูกเอสสีไวโอลินเป็นไหมอ่ะ We  Are สีได้
แต่สีไม่เป็นไม่เรียนหรอกอะไร
ไม่ไหวๆสีน่ะได้แต่สีไม่เป็น
ฟังแล้วแบบไม่เข้าใจ
เอาไวโอลินมาแล้วครูเอ๋สีอันเนี่ยกู F4
ได้นะคะแบบสีไม่เป็นคือคนที่สีไวโอลิน
เป็นก็สีแล้วทุกคนฟัง
โอ้ยเก่งจังตายแต่ผู้หญิงคู๋
OS  OS ติ๊ดไม่เอาไว้โฟนสีได้สีไม่เป็น
เหมือนกีตาร์นะดีดได้ดีดไม่เป็นผู้หญิงมี
อีกค่ะอะไรใครคะครูเอ๋อันนี้ครูเหรียญ
แล้วนะเรียนแล้ว
ลองเนี่ยนะคะแต่ไม่เคยเรียนโต๋แล้วเวลา
เราจะเล่นกลองเนี่ยเราเล่นยังไงเราดี
เหมือนกีตาร์เราสีเหมือนไวโอลินไหมไม่ใช่
ค่ะกูหญิงเหงาต้องตีอันนี้ชอบเนาะไอ้
ใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋นี่ไงนี่ไงมาใช้มือตีไหมเอ่อ
ใช้มือใช้ใช่มือตีค่ะมีไม้นะคะมีมากูเห็น
ไม่ใช่มีไม้แต่ว่าใช้เท้าด้วยที่อ๋อนิทาน
ยังไงมึงปืน
มันจะมีที่เท้าให้กดใช่ไหมถ้าขอใช้ไม้หนอ
ใช้เบอร์จับไม้แล้วก็ติดงั้นครูเอ๋ก็ตี
กลองเป็นไม่ใช่ได้นะเป็น
เลือกสีได้ค่ะก็คุยเรียนแล้วไม่ใช่เหรอคะ
เรียนแล้วก็ไม่เก่งค่ะก็เลยโอเคสีได้แต่
สีมันจะหยุดค่ะหยุดค่ะหยุดตีกลองตอนเรียน
เขาบอกว่ามือเนี่ยข้อมือตัวนี้ข้อมือใช่
ไหมคะเขาให้อย่างนี้อ๋อ
ต้องขยับข้อมือไม่ต้องขยับแขนใดๆข้อมูล
อันกรองไทยและตัวเอง
West
ครูบอกออกไป
ก็เลยตีได้หรอแต่ตีไม่เป็นปีได้ตี๋ไม่
เป็นค่ะอยากให้ผู้หญิงนี่ค่ะ
รู้ไหมคะอันนี้อะไร
saxophone อ่อนแล้วเวลาเล่นเซ็กโซโฟนเรา
เล่นยังไงดีไม่ใช่ตี๋ไม่ใช่ตีถ้าไม่ใช่
แล้วทำยังไงเป่าค่ะใช้อะไรเป่าคะปากค่ะ
ต่อเก่งมากค่ะนี่นี่เห็นไหมผู้หญิงไม่
ต้องเองครูเอ๋เป่าแซกโซโฟนได้ไหมคะ
เป็นไหมคะเป่าได้เป่าไม่เป็น
งู
ปิดจะถามทำไมเนาะนักเรียนถามเอาก็ถามให้
นักเรียนฟัง
เรียนเหมือนกันผู้หญิงไม่ต้องเรียน
ต้องเรียนเข้ามาปุ๊บเวทจับขึ้นมาโอเคไม่
ต้องเป่าหูอันนี้ต้องแบบแข็งแรงมากๆเลยนะ
เป๋าใส่โซโฟนอ้าไม่ต้องปอดใหญ่ๆฮือวิ่ง
ต้องว่ายน้ำนะคะตายค่ะแต่ว่าไป 1 ครั้ง
หรือเปล่าแล้วก็เออเออโอเคสวัสดี
saxophone เหนื่อยอ่ะฝั่งดีกว่าใช่ไหม
ครูเอ๋ไอ้ใช่แต่ว่านี้มันเป็นเครื่อง
ดนตรีของนักเรียนไง
ไม่สนุกค่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยจะมีเครื่องดนตรี
ไทยของไทยให้นักเรียนคิดใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋
คิดค่ะดีดสีตีหรือเปล่าใครค่ะฟรีมีบางอัน
ขยับด้วยนะคุย
อีกน่าจะไม่มีนะหรือเปล่ารู้นะคะครูเอ๋คะ
อันนี้อะไรคะกลองยาว
กลองยาวเนี่ยเล่นยังไงดีสีตีหรือว่าเป่า
ครูเอกคิดว่า
ตีค่ะตีๆ
หัวหน้าไอ้ค่ะครู
เองถึงตรงๆ
จะหมดโมงโมงถึงมีงง
ทำไมผมถึงแล้วแต่นักเรียนรองเนี่ยคนที่ตี
เก่งๆเขาจะมีเทคนิคดีให้เสียงไม่เหมือน
กันคุยถึงก็ไม่เข้าใจเหมือนกัน
วงสิงค์โปร์กระโปรงก็ถูกนะจริงๆเนาะกลอง
ก็ตีค่ะ
ตายนี่ไงเห็นไหม
นั่งนั่งตีก็ได้
ยืนอันนี้เดินตีราไม้ตรี
ใส่ไข่ไหมผู้ชายตีกลองผู้หญิงรำเรียกว่า
อะไรคะเนี้ยวงอันนี้เรียกว่าวงอะไรนะรำรำ
จันทร์ยาวเลยใช่ก็เคยรำแล้วทำไมลืมนะคะ
อ่ะตัวเองเคยรำนะคะแต่ไม่ใช่นี่ก็
มีกล้องยาวคู๋ผู้หญิงชื่อกองยาวแล้วนะก็
ใหม่ๆค่ะคุณเป็นคนนี้ค่ะคุณเป็นคนรำแต่
ไม่มีคนนี้นะคะนักเรียนอ๋อมีเป็นดนตรีใช่
ไหมคะคือตัวนี้ก็ตีตีแต่ไม่ได้รำคู่กัน
[เพลง]
เคยเรียนครูหญิง vs ตีกลองยาวเป็นเหรอคะ
ครูเอ๋เรียนรำกลองยาวเป็นเป็นคนนี้เหมือน
กันค่ะเป็นคุยจะเขียนได้ไหมสักครู่นะคะ
นายค่ะเป็น
คนนี้คนนี้
เป็นผู้หญิงแล้วก็เรียนค่ะเรียนกะเวลาดี
ดีเรียนแล้วก็รำเรียนเสร็จครูบอกออกไปคุณ
มาก
มือ
โอเคอ่ามีแต่ว่าเดิน
ไม่สวย
ใช่ไม่เป็น
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าผู้หญิงใหญ่ผู้หญิงจะตีกลอง
ยาวไม่ได้เนาะมันไม่ตีก่อนไม่ตีและผู้ชาย
ชายปีผู้หญิงนิดหน่อยตึงหนึ่งเมื่อเรานะ
คะจ่ายมีอีกครั้งคู๋ค่ะมีอะไรอีกขา
เครื่องดนตรีชิ้นต่อไปเครื่องดนตรีอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวนะจริงๆหญิงนี่ภาษา
ไทยนะแต่กูยังไงเรียน
จะเข้าถูกค่ะค่ะจะเคจะเข้เล่นยังไงดีสีตี
หรือว่าหัวเปล่า
เดี๋ยวนะคะนักเรียนมีอะไรนะดีเหตุสีตี
ดีหรือเปล่าๆถ้าไม่น่าจะใช่แล้วนะเป่าได้
ไม่ใช่หรอกเป่าได้ไม่ใช่อ่า
ดีดปีนะไม่ใช่
เหลือแต่ดีดกับสีลืมเอาคิมมา
อะไรอ่ะดีดกับสีอันนี้กูเอ๋ไม่ต้องเลือก
แล้วค่ะว่าดีนะหรือสี
นี่ค่ะที่นะมาดูเดชเบรค
ใช่ค่า
อันนี้ดีดนะนักเรียนเห็นไหมเขาจะมี
ใส่มือแล้วก็ดีอ่ะพี่เอ๋ดีจะใข้เป็นไหมคะ
ไม่เป็นไม่เป็นไม่เคยเรียนใช่อ่ะยังไม่
รู้เลยว่าดีดหรือสี
ก็ไม่เป็นเหมือนกันค่ะอ่ะติดต่อใบค่ะครู
เอ๋
รู้จักค่ะเรียกว่าอะไรคะเครื่องดนตรีชิ้น
นี้ซอ
ซอเล่นยังไงดีสีตีหรือว่าเป่าสี 5  4
กูไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรครับไม่เป็นไรไม่
เป็นไรกูอ่ะ
ไม่เจอไอ้เก่งนะกูเองไปดูสิคะ
ใช่ค่ะเห็นไหมแต่นั่งเล่นเนาะค่ะอ่านั่ง
เล่นแล้วก็ตั้งตั้งตรวจสอบขึ้นแล้วก็เอา
ไม้สีนะคะเห็นนะคะที่ฉันก็ทำให้เป็นสี่
ค่ะอันนี้เป็นไม้ที่ 4 สีนะคะคุณเอ๋สีสว
เป็นไหมคะไม่ใช่ได้นะเป็นไว้นะไม่เป็นไม่
เป็น
ไม่เป็นสัตว์ผู้หญิงเหมือนกันโอเค
ไม่ใช่มีอีกแค่คู๋
เขตชอบอะไรครับรูเอกเครื่องดนตรีชิ้นนี้
ระนาดงานระนาดเนี่ยเล่นยังไงดีสี
ๆหรือว่าเป่าครูหญิงเห็นไม้ไหมคะเห็นค่ะ
ไม้ระนาดนะคะ
แล้วก็มีลูกระนาดใช่ไหมอันนี้ใช่ไหมอัน
นี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ๆก็เรียนรู้แล้วนะ
แพงแพงของรณจะมีรูปและหน้าแล้วก็มันแผลก็
ตี่
สี่
เก่งนะ Action เก่งนะเคยตีโหแต่ว่าไม่
เป็น
นี่หละนี้ใช้ค่ะตีอันนี้รูปสัตว์หน้าร้อน
ไทยนะคะไทยทรามา
ทำไมนี่แฟนเราพี่หนุ่มศรรามนะแต่ว่าเวลา
ตีทั้งหมดมือต้องเท่าเดิมใช่ไหมผู้เหมือ
ที่จับไม้ข้างหลังตรงนั้นหลังตรงให้แล้ว
ก็ข้อมือเนี่ยข้อมือต้องแข็งแรงค่ะระนาด
ก็มากๆผู้ชายผู้ชายตีใช่เขาไม่ให้ผู้หญิง
ตีให้ค่ะผู้แต่ว่าไปตีสายแต่ซอสามสายผู้
หญิงตีและผู้หญิงซิงสีดำสีได้ตะเข้ผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงได้ผู้ชายก็ได้กับผู้
ชายมากกว่าไหมหรอพี่ก็ว่างั้นนั้นในรูปก็
ผู้ชายนะดูสิขา
มีอีกทั้งคู๋แล้วนะง่ายๆอะไรคะ
ขลุ่ยค่ะอ่ะปุ๋ยเนี่ยจะเล่นยังไงดีสีตี
หรือเปล่า
ตีก็ได้นะอาจจะดีก็ได้นะเบี้ยกัน
เป่าค่ะเต่าๆ
โอ้วชัยค่ะเป่า
คู๋
เป่าขลุ่ยเป็นไหมไม่เป็นเลยเรียนไหมคะเคย
ค่ะแล้วก็เอากล้วยวางแล้วก็สวัสดีบ๊ายบาย
ผู้หญิงที่มากกล้วยเอาคุยมาแล้วก็
เป่าแบบนี้มันต้องมีแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยเวลา
เป่าต้อง
คุยเสียงเพราะแต่กูเอง
นักเรียนเนี้ยเอ้อนักเรียนเมื่อก่อนนะคะ
ถ้าหรือผู้ชายเนี่ยชอบผู้หญิง
เขาคุยนะผู้หญิงก็จะฟังแล้วเจ้างูไอ้อาย
เป็นนะเนี่ย Action ไงแต่ว่า
ไม่ใช่ 2020  2022 ไม่มีแล้วค่ะ
ธุรกประมาณผู้หญิงวัยรุ่นเนาะปี
2010 ผู้ชายต้องดีดกีตาร์นะคะชอบผู้หญิง
เนี่ยดีดกีตาร์เปล่านะคะไม่เข้าใจอะไร
อะไรแต่นักเรียนขลุ่ยฟังแล้วเพราะรู้แมน
ติกเอามาเด็กชายนะก็แต่ส่วนใหญ่ผู้ชายนะ
ผู้หญิงก็ได้เนาะอะมีอีกทักครูเอ๋
ขออะไรคะ
คล้ายๆรณัฐน็องต์ล้างโกงไลน์เล่นยังไงดีด
สีตีดีหรือเป่า
เปล่าไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงเห็นไม้ไม่มายมีสองมาไม้ 2 ไม้
เห็นอ่ะอ่ะเอาไว้ตีค่ะตีพอ
ใช่ค่ะนั่งตีก็ได้นะเหลือยืนตีก็ได้ใช่
ค่ะโอเคมีกี่แค่ตัวเอง
อะไรครับครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวนะคุยลืม
can อ่า can ภาษาอังกฤษเหรอคะ I  can
ออก
อ่ะ
Hand
เล่นยังไงดีสีตีหรือว่าเป่าเป่าค่ะ
โอ้วไปดูสิว่าเล่นเป็นด้วยนะแต่ว่าปรับ
ใช่ดูคนอื่นใช่ไหม
คะเห็นไว้ไว้ค่ะมีสายใดต้องตัดแบบนี้เนาะ
ครับจับจับตรงสีดำๆค่ะค่ะใช่ไหมคะนัก
เรียนจับตรงนี้เนอะแล้วก็ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมที่
เป่าอ๋อแล้วก็ไม่รู้ไงผู้หญิงเห็นรูไหม
ดูดมดูใกล้ๆสีดำๆ
ไม่เห็นหน้าเห็นแค่เห็นหน่อยตรงนี้หรอใช่
ซักมีกำลังดูอยู่ในว่าอีกรูปนึงน่ะเขาหัน
ยังไงเอาใช่ค่ะพี่ดูผิดนะคะใช่ค่ะเอาตรง
นี้เป่าตรงนี้แล้วตอนนิ้วนิ้วต้องขยับ
อะไรตามตรงนี้ปิดเปิดปิดเปิดเนี่ยกูอ่ะทำ
ไม่เป็นคุยเอาแขนมาแล้วเนาะมึง
แล้วก็เกรงหยุดถ้า
เป่าได้แต่ไม่เป็นเพลงค่ะหญิงมีอีกค่ะ
เครื่องดนตรีไทยอะไรคะอ๋อ
เรรู้ไหมเรียกอะไรเดี๋ยวนะคะแต่ไม่แน่ใจ
ไม้จะกลับล่ะ
ฉันก็พอค่ะสั้นๆก็พอค่ะกลับใช่ค่ะกลับ
กลับนะคะกลับเล่นยังไง
ดีสินตีหรือเปล่า
มีด้วยกันใช่มั้ย
ไม่รู้เขาใช้มือเดียวใช่ไหมผู้หญิงไม่เอา
ใช้มือเดียวพี่เอ๋เอาเอามาแล้วก็ตีอ่ะ
แต่ว่าไอ้เรานี่เนี่ยนดูสิทำได้ยังไงอ่ะ
นี่ในมื้อเดียวนะนี่คือมีกลับ 2 คู่ราคา 1
สิ่งที่จะยากเนาะยากได้ๆ
ครูเอกเคยรู้จักคนที่ที่เล่นกลับ
แล้วก็ให้คุยลอง
ก็ไม่ได้มันต้องทั้งใช้แล้วก็ขวาเราเก่ง
ทั้งมือซ้ายมือขวาเลยนะใช่มือนั่งมือนะคะ
นักเรียนตรงนี้จะมีกล้ามขอโทษนะคะแผน
เนี้ยตรงนี้เป็นกล้ามมีไม่เห็นไหมห้ามไม่
มีไม่เห็นตอนนี้ค่ะเนี้ยกล้ามนะคะถ้า
สนิทกรามกล้ามคู๋นะไม่แข็งแรงแต่ว่าถ้า
มือเนี่ยคนที่เล่นแอปมือต้องมีกล้ามกล้าม
มือแข็งแรงใช่เพราะต้องแบบเรากลับ 2 อัน
น่ะนะทำไม๊เล่น
ไม่รู้อ่ะต้องตีเราจะเอาออกให้ได้ปีแล้ว
ก็เอาออกโอเคเก่งมากนะๆดูเหมือนไม่เก่ง
แต่ต้องเก่งมากนะคะให้ดูแบบง่ายๆเออ
มีอีกค่ะครูเอ๋อะไรอ่ะ
มา
เร็วๆเมื่อกี้มีไปแล้วซออันนี้ไม่ใช่ซอ
หรอไม่ใช้ซองอะดีเนี่ยเชียงใหม่เชียงราย
ภาคเหนือประเทศไทยใช่ไหมชินไม่ใช่พิณพิณ
วันที่ศาลเอาเหรออะไรอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวๆอันนี้อะไรคุยเห็นหรือไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะเพราะพี่ก็ไม่รู้หรอกค่ะฉันรออ๋ออ๋อ
สะล้อซอซึงโอเคอ่ะสะล้อเล่นยังไงกู a  r
ดีดสีตีเป่าสีค่ะสีไปดูนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะสี
จะลองสองปีกนะคะสีสะล้อไม่ใช่ซอเหรอ
กู any อีกค่ะ
พิณผู้หญิงก็เขียนภาษาไทยนะกูเองคะซึ่ง
ไปไม่ได้ดูเอกคิดว่าสุดนักเรียนเดี๋ยว
เครื่องดนตรีไทยแต่ว่าครูเอ๋น่ะไม่รู้ทุก
อย่างนะคะผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้อ่ะคุย
อ่ะซื้อซึ่งเกลียดคิดว่าซึ่งเล่นยังไงดี
สีตีหรือเปล่า
ดีดค่ะเดรสเท่านั้นทั้งๆที่บ้า
เก่งมากๆนะคะผู้หญิงมีอีกมั้ย
เอ้า
ปี่
EP เล่นยังไงคะครูเอ๋มีอะไรให้ดึงออกมา
ด้วยนะคะนี่ไงนี่ไงมีอันนี้ลิ้นปี่ลิ้น
ของมันเป็นของมันเอาไว้ดึงเหรอคะก็ไม่ใจ
ถ้าเอาไว้เป่าขอบคุณหลัง 5
เทคนิค ooooo  aaaaa นะคะ
ปี่เป่าค่ะนี่ค่ะค่ะใช่ไหมเปล่าก็เสียง
ยังไง
[เพลง]
ถ้านักเรียนเคยเกิดสู้มันตัดเสียงเราคู๋
ถ้านักเรียนเคยดูมวยไทยจะได้ยินเสียงปี่
ลองใหม่เรามัน
[เพลง]
คำเฉียบ Copy ยังไม่โอเคเลยเนาะไม่รู้ดิ
เห็นบอกเอโลดี้ 0 คะแนนนักเรียนบอกครู
หญิงพูดไม่ดีครูเอ๋
พี่ก็ไม่ได้ไงบ้านครูเอ๋ทุกคนไม่เก่งฮาๆ
หรือทราย
ดนตรีไม่เก็บ
หมดแล้วไม่ทิ้งค
จะเล่นยังไงฉิ่งใช้
ตีค่ะดีดสีตีเป่าตีค่ะตี้
ใช่ค่ะตีอันนี้ก็ต้องเก่งนะคะดูง่ายๆแต่
ไม่ง่ายนะตีฉิ่งน่ะใช่ซึ่งจัดจริงสัตว์
ชิงจับชิ่งจับ of เพราะว่าในทีมดนตรีไทย
ต้องฟังฉิ่งเอา
สิ่งก็เหมือนคนรักเตอร์เหรอใช่ซึ่งจากมา
เลย์เคยตี
โอเคไหมคะฟังแล้วดีทุกคนดีดผิด
หัวใจตั้งแต่ปีแล้วค่ะแอร์แอร์อีพีเอไอ
เอสแอร์อีซี AEC  and เร็ว
มีครู 1 คนให้ครูเอ๋น่ะตี 4 ปีที่ 1 ราคา
ตรีสิงห์พอตีนทิ้งเสร็จครูครูที่ตีกลอง
ครูที่นะเป่าแคนบอกว่าหยุดปวดหัวออกไป
ก็ไม่ได้ไงคุยกับทุกคนต้องฟังฉิ่งฉิ่ง
ต้องเก่งไง
ใช่เอกชอบชิงนะคะเอาแต่ไม่มีข่าว
ผู้หญิงนี่อันหนึ่งที่ครูพูดอ่าเผิ่นทราย
พิณเล่นยังไงดีดีสีสีตีหรือเป่าดีดไหมค่ะ
ดีดไหมไปดูเอานะคะคุณเอ๋
ใช่ค่ะเหมือนกีตาร์เนาะค่ะเหมือนเหมือน
กีตาร์เหมือนอะไรนะอันนึง
ผู้หญิงเปิดเนี้ยอะไรอ่ะอ่าซึ่ง
เนื้อหาซึ่งดีดนะคะผู้หญิงอีกอันนึงค่ะกู
อ่ะสุดท้าย
ถ่าบอ่ะถ้าเป๊กเหมือนชิงไหมอา
ให้คล้ายๆแต่ฉาบใหญ่อา
ฉาบเล่นยังไงคะครูเอ๋ DVD ได้ตี
det ป่าวตีของ
ใจไงคุยเป็นลิง
หาเพลงเดี๋ยวจะตีฉาบวง
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงครูเองมีคำถามอะไรคะ
เปลี่ยนโอ
ผู้หญิงไม่มีใช่ไหมนานไม่มีเลย
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีพี่หมดแล้วเปลี่ยนโอเคกู n
ถามผู้หญิง Piano อันเนี้ยดีสี 4 เป่าดี
ค่ะ
บีบมันต้องอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมคะก็ดีดอย่างนี้
ไงดีดอันนี้กดไม่ใช่แต่เขาดีดเปียโนใช่
มั้ยไม่เข้าใจเขาเล่นดีดเปียโนกันดีด
เนี่ยเราจะรู้ว่าเป็นแบบนี้ใช่นะดีดใช่
ไหมคะใช่ๆสั่นกดกดตรงไปเหมือนนี่ไงเหมือน
พิมพ์คอมพิวเตอร์เลยครูเอ๋เอ๋เมื่อก่อน
ไม่มีคอมพิวเตอร์ก็พิมพ์ดีดเออคิดว่าเขา
ก็ได้ว่าดีดเป็นโนครูเอ๋ทำไมพูดดีดเป็น No
เลยเอ่อเป็นโอโอเคให้คุยกันล้อเล่นเปียโน
โอเคพูดเล่นเพราะกูอีกแล้วบีบตรงไหน
กดติดนิ้วไงใช้นิ้วโอเคคิดว่านะก็อันนี้
เป็นเครื่องดนตรีไทยน้อบางเครื่องก็เล่น
อ่ะดีนะคะบางอย่างมันก็สี
ตีแล้วก็เป่าถ้าใครนะคะวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
นะผู้หญิงกับครูเอกก็ต้องไปแล้วนะเดี๋ยว
เจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายๆ